welcome to the yearly Japanese cop
racing
my name is 1010 30-pin yeah I need a nut
[ __ ] I need him not a pimp to bat again
if only there were someone else
hello there my name is Professor Jacob
soupy
buy yourself a house buy your mother a
house buy your whole family a house I
don't need your charity money then I
suggest we bet
I suggest we bet as well it's been 84
years since you showed your face around
these parts I hope you got the money on
the balls oh my got planning
oh look saves Tappan again this not
working on those triceps I see that's my
girl
the best mother welcome she she doubles
$400 on France 30 more honey does cranes
ain't got [ __ ] him he got a dildo on his
head and now that's a jelly bean I can't
see [ __ ] what country is that
oh that is Iran Australia's returned on
his ceiling what the hell is that I'm
quoting 400 [ __ ] they used to call my
mother that's old you're not lost my
Anushka numbness I know well about that
one trust me
820 Oni what the [ __ ] is America doing
there's nine of them now was he on the I
don't think Americans ought yeah from
power range I mean was he on the Dragons
ole from power race
come on who did I bet on I forgot
come on New Zealand come on over a lea I
didn't get getting more like confetti
sorry you don't throw the money honey
it's real money shut up respect the
money oh [ __ ] oh man he's down O'Shea
he's charging the brofist whatever
country that is I wish I bet it on them
Sweden now that's Sweden [ __ ] yeah
that's sweet girl
trust me it could be anyone's race my
girls are stretching it out come on baby
our boys are the girls do a showing
charging ready to go are you talking
that one didn't you oh [ __ ] oh no I
don't think so don't you man to man to
Patti Cochrane girls now where the hell
are ya lose the money the money goes to
charity starving children you okay
fifteen hundred thousand dollars on the
Trojan horse the Trojan but I'm gonna go
on the fringe ladies French ladies come
on French ladies you'll never be the
pimp your father what the [ __ ] happened
other ninja uses a [ __ ] the Rudin
boom oh my god oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] no no no
no what is [ __ ] yo
Sweden betting on friends my lady's
gonna do it this time I'm gonna bet 400
million dollars on the sea lion I raised
you six billion dollars on not those
money on Elvis dildo Elvis dildo Elvis
Oh what is all Elvis it knows no come on
now
haha oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that what
are you girls my club it's my cookies
not my club that is who she is Breanna
that's right these winnings of mine
thank you yeah thank you very much your
paper this say my name Jeezy Akali I'll
place all my winnings on their route oh
I'm gonna go on the French ladies six
million dollars and then I'm gonna go on
ah
Naruto's mom Oh baby no RunAs mom no yes
like this Yoshi and Yoshi Boop all I'm
gonna hire that sear that seal is gonna
be a star I'm gonna take that seal the
Hollywood come on shoot come on keep
bouncing yes yes this is [ __ ] great
and you know okay all the money in
France Naruto I'll bet the charity fund
on their route it's here I bet my hat on
Troy North Troy on horse yes Troy and
horse I'm gonna throw in my moustache
horsey you're a madman
oh [ __ ] no no no no I wrote oh yes no no
been leaving the power of your keys oh
wait that's dragon Sasuke where Sasuke
yes there's so much monkey a bat my home
pension on frunch Naruto Naruto a brave
man oh like a human I'm betting 50 on
Japan too late no I just matter pimples
oh my oh my batting my coat on eight
come on $800 on 8:20 goes online oh nine
if students I'm [ __ ] no row your boat
eighth row your boat arranger roll your
board eight come on come on
eight I get your head now and you'll
find us all but a stupid girl even said
I'm gonna go with nobody to know I'll go
I know who will come nine number nine
how many room but I'm betting twenty
dollars on nine trip come on she our
King jr. that Mainichi Sudoku okay come
on Arnie nobody won't you come on come
on nine I bet all night come on my eyes
that's why I paint never takes off his
glasses
come on i-29 come by and fill him jail
we both bet on sight yeah well by what a
what a fine race day we had here take
loose allowance wait my allowance but
only my father could give me an
allowance
don't you see
I am your father and I will be with you
always
dad no remember who you are
Simba remember remember
you